the biggest thing for me and that i
notice with our audience and people that
call in is uh
is just pornography just the inability
to
i i don't know if we're even genetically
able to
battle how powerful yeah it is i agree
with you and i i think we've
grossly underestimated the power was
that dude's picture up there
i was just we don't have to acknowledge
it i was just showing theo a relevant
video question we have okay oh that's
cool but is it pertaining to porn
addiction
uh masturbation and i think he mentions
his porns what made him fill up do it
okay let's do it
what's up theo hope you're doing well
i'm kai
from gold coast australia yeah he is um
i wanted to talk to you
about your struggle to not touch your
little wang
um just because i've been having the
same struggle
and last night i woke up from one of
those sweet sweet dreams
and i touched my wang and normally
that's not that's not too bad of a thing
but
this is my 27th day in a row i'm not
doing it i'm not doing something
to make it to 100 because previously i
tried nofap november
which is where you know you don't fap
for all of november
which is something i think you should
encourage amongst your viewers and we
should
probably promote that we'll look it up
but yeah it's tough man it's hard
so just letting you know that i'm
struggling with the fight as well
and keep going with it gang man that's
cool well yeah i'm not so sure
you know uh it sounds like in a
restaurant or something instead
i mean who knows where he was he could
have been outdoors he could have been
who knows looking at children at a park
you never know oh god
i assume he wasn't but yeah i think but
he did seem genuine in that i think he
tried to not masturbate and so he
must have identified that as a problem
which is why he was trying to do
something about it
and the average person should be looking
for balance right not absolute
abstinence but if you have a problem
where you're hurting yourself or you're
affecting your
livelihood or your relationships well
yeah you got to go through withdrawal
yeah you ever heard of circle plans oh
yeah like the
inner middle and yeah yeah because i've
gone to saa which is sex addicts
anonymous before
and um i think so a lot of our original
listeners knew this but
uh and yeah they would have three three
circles and i need to actually get back
into it i'm going to a therapist today
actually good for you
um i just struggle yeah i mean the
masturbation thing
for me when i would eject when i would
ejaculate i would feel
shame shame yeah and so the you know
men that have sexual addictions usually
had emotional abuse in childhood but you
can have sexual abuse too but but
emotional abuse is very common
antecedent to sexual abuse and man or
sexual compulsions of various type
and you know we did that show sex
addiction yeah
and it was very interesting some of
those people now are doing great i mean
you should interview some of them
that would be fascinating jenny ketchum
she's like a social worker now
and uh oh yeah she went back to oh she's
a she just had a baby i mean a guy
she's amazing does that inspire you how
do you feel when you see that kind of
stuff
i love it it gets what it does it gets
me the next day it's like
and sometimes what i really like is when
they're ones that i had no hope for
which because because that always makes
me humble like
there's hope for anybody right this one
i never gave that one a chance and now
he's a psychologist like
it's anything's possible so although i
still will kick
you know when i'm when i'm running a
program i will keep people out and i
will be very tough on them
that's just what they need right then
right it doesn't mean they can't get
well one day
right so uh just i can't enable them i
can't be part of the problem that kind
of stuff
yeah but yeah i would feel shame i would
just feel ashamed you know yeah and so
you know if you if you the shame may be
purely psychological doesn't mean
because you have a sexual compulsion
necessarily it depends on
you know what was giving you the shame
but there was something legitimately
like you didn't want to do you kept
doing
right um and if it was not just
affecting your
affecting your safety and your health
that kind of stuff that's something to
look into
um and again sex addiction there's has
to be a period of abstinence you go
through some withdrawal you put certain
things in the inner circle that you
cannot do you put slippery stuff in the
next circle and you put
healthy stuff in the outer circle yeah
and you work with a sponsor on moving
things in and out of that
yeah kind of scrub your electronic media
yeah yeah i think i i really do i just
got to focus more i've been doing better
than i was a couple years ago for sure
and i find if i like am doing something
that i value
that i don't even think about um acting
out
so you feel yourself right is it is it
an emptiness you're trying to
is like other addictions you can feel
empty i just get antsy like i'll just
get home and i'll just feel like maybe
there was one time i noticed like a girl
that i thought was cute
i didn't end up going to talk to her i
have no clue if she was
70 or 22. it's kind of far
i had no idea but i put her on this
weird little pedestal suddenly in my
head yeah
i didn't talk to her at all i left and
went home and then i just
felt uh i just felt just worthless
so so the little pedestal sort of a love
addiction thing right like you elevate
somebody make them perfect yeah you got
to have them
she could be horrible she could have
been a man it wasn't even that clear how
far away she was
you know but i had put her in this
special place and i went home and i just
felt defeated and i was
next you know i'm looking at like
escorts on the internet i'm not getting
them but i'm like bartering with them
oh yeah sh the dude who's like bartering
with an escort but not even gonna buy it
like 40
less you know and well but the the
problem with that is all of a sudden
you're there
right that's the that's yeah you're so
close yeah it's like flirting with uh if
you're alcoholic and you go and drink
near beer like
yeah now you're flirting right it's like
having arms made of gas and playing with
matches
yeah gas arms i'm just sitting on your
front porch
wondering how could i be so far from my
home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
blown